[Musica]
Buon pomeriggio Buon pomeriggio lo sai
che è tutta chimica ma proprio tutto
praticamente Chimica tutto quello che ci
circonda e chimica anche l'amore chimica
soltanto che l'amore poi parte da qui lo
sapete cosa sono queste
No non mi Guardate Così non dovete
ridere perché in realtà non è come
sembra sono i due lobi dell'ipofisi Ok
non era quello che pensavate perché in
realtà L'amore prima di essere chimica è
anche un'idea che si forma nel nostro
cervello e noi esseri umani siamo stati
bravissimi a dipingere quest'idea
partiamo dai cartoni animati dato che
ora c'è stata la Sirenetta Guardate un
po' quello che ho sono parecchie cose lo
so insomma quel che è lei vuole far
andar via le sue bellissime pinne Anzi
la sua grande pinna per mettersi le
gambe e scappare dal suo grande amato
Ecco una cosa che io non suggerirei mai
alla Sirenetta direi scappa nel profondo
dell'oceano Non andargli dietro ma anche
per esempio le principesse della Disney
i loro rincorrono Questo amore
bellissimo e si intende L'amore come
qualcosa di predestinato qualcosa che ci
sta per arrivare incontriamo lui
incontriamo lei diciamo era quello che
il destino mi ha messo davanti tant'è
che alcuni vanno anche dai maghi io ci
ho messo Harry Potter però ecco I maghi
ci sono maghi ben più spiacevoli di
Harry Potter che ci illudono che la
persona amata con un qualche incantesimo
forse col destino ci ricambierà in
realtà in realtà non bisogna andare dal
mago dovete venire da me per l'amore
perché l'amore è tutta chimica tutta
totalmente chimica Certo è una chimica
anche che parte da lontano perché le
prime i primi esseri viventi che hanno
cominciato a capire e a sfruttare la
chimica per fare l'amore sono state le
piante 460 milioni di anni fa le prime
piante sono arrivate sulla terra Ho
detto Sai che c'è facciamo l'amore dice
Se no che fai in quella Napoli Facciamo
almeno l'amore e l'hanno fatto bene le
piante perché hanno cominciato intanto a
travestirsi di colori meravigliosi per
fare l'amore pensate al Rosso appunto
del papavero o i vari colori che sono lì
antociani dal dal rosso anche loro al
Viola al giallo per esempio poi gli
scienziati hanno anche classificato
queste moleco colorate sempre mettendoci
un po' di sesso perché gli scienziati un
po' nerd sono un po' fissati il rosso Eh
il licopene per esempio Ma ci sono anche
molecole
alcaloidi che sono psicotropi che
venivano usati anche come sostanze per
far confessare il siero della verità
della natura stramonium che è una
molecola che si chiama scopolamina scopo
la mina Vabbè è così gli scienziati
hanno tutta questa grande fantasia
sessuale ma ci sono anche altre molecole
come i terpeni gli odori servono alle
piante per fare l'amore per amarsi tra
di loro perché mediano interazione con
gli insetti Ma quando parliamo anche di
travestitismo perché anche l'essere
umano fa l'amore Delle volte ci si
traveste per fare l'amore c'è chi ama i
giochi di ruolo chi ne fa altri
travestitissimi e qualcuno anche se non
ridisce perché dice Mamma mia Queste
pratiche così ma le piante hanno
cominciato a 460 milioni di anni fa
travestirsi l'orchidea l'orchizza pifera
si travestiva da ape Perché Perché il
maschio dell'ape vedeva all'orchidea di
questo fiore dice Ecco una femmina Pam
si appoggiava sopra l'organo funerale
cominciava un sussulto di amore sesso
per arrivare a l'eiaculazione perché
anche le api eiaculano e hanno un
orgasmo Il problema è che sul loki sa
Pip era l'ape l'orgasmo non ce l'ha per
cui se ne va via insoddisfatta la per
cercare un'altra ape capita male perché
accanto al fiore dell'orchidea
probabilmente c'è un'altra orchi
sapifera su cui si appoggerà e rimarrà
insoddisfatto un'altra volta quindi
l'orchi sapifera sull'insoddisfazione
altrui l'insoddisfazione sessuale altrui
si riproduce e si impollina ma non solo
c'è anche lui Indovinate come l'hanno
chiamato questi diciamo non erano ancora
scienziati potremmo dire Gli scienziati
dell'epoca il fallus impudicus Chissà
perché e il fallous impudicus è un fungo
che produce delle sostanze che sono la
putriscina la cadaverina che attirano
numerosissime mosche che servono per
portare le spore del fungo in giro ci
sono piante che hanno anche schiavizzato
alcuni animali alcuni Botticelli Questo
è il dodo il dodo Poverino è stato
estinto dall'uomo Perché un uccello
goffo che si muove così insomma in modo
molto goffo almeno si muoveva in questo
modo veniva preso a sassate ucciso
veramente MHM meschinamente e il dodo
era necessario per far riprodurre la
caldaia marior che è una pianta il cui
seme è un segmento molto rigido e
serviva il dodo per nel suo ventriglio
per rompere il documento e far sì che il
seme potesse germogliare morto il dodo
la pianta si stava per estinguere
fortunatamente poi gli scienziati hanno
capito che anche i tacchini potevano
svolgere la stessa cosa e quindi hanno
trovato un sostituto Ma la chimica
dell'amore si espansa anche negli
insetti pensate alla chemiluminescenza
la chemiluminescenza Sono reazioni
chimiche che nello specifico nella
Lucciola l'esempio più bello che abbiamo
a disposizione si ossida la luciferina
grazie a un enzima e si produce ossido
ciferina e luce a seconda del ritmo del
culetto bioreattore della Lucciola le
lucciole si capiscono e sono più o meno
pronte per accoppiarsi poi ci sono anche
gli esseri umani anzi prima Cioè le
meduse le meduse fanno altrettanto e poi
ci sono anche gli esseri umani che
utilizzano appunto questi bellissimi
glowstick perché Beh in effetti Ecco ora
noi esseri umani non li usiamo per
accoppiarci almeno spero che nessuno li
usi con questo scopo ma anche il
glowstic che segnala la nostra presenza
in discoteca ma anche a pescare per
esempio è basato su una reazione chimica
una reazione chimica che fa luce come
con l'acqua ossigenata con
difenirossalato che è un essere
praticamente che ossidato dall'acqua
ossigenata sforma un però sia acido una
molecola molto compressa che Bam si apre
la rottura del legame chimico eccita il
colorante Ecco almeno il colorante È
citato in tutto questo giro di grandi
reazioni e emette luce ecco l'amore se
vogliamo Grazie a tutte queste reazioni
chimiche è interazione Diciamo che la
chimica viene sfruttata per creare
interazione Ma nella stessa chimica c'è
dell'amore amore che io declino in tutte
le forme Anche verso un animale
attraverso il compagno la compagna
qualsiasi forma essa sia perché tutta la
natura si basa su forme di attrazione di
interrelazione ma di attrazione queste
forme di attrazione non sono solo forze
attrattive ed interazione attrattiva ma
anche repulsiva e possiamo dividere le
persone Quelle attratte dalla banana e
quelle che invece la banana la allontana
Ecco Queste forme di interazione cosmica
che fonda l'universo dalla forza di
colum che sulle forze elettriche alla
forza gravitazionale in realtà Giocano
un ruolo fondamentale anche nelle
molecole ma soprattutto le molecole sono
un ottimo esempio e possono essere prese
come un parallelismo tra come noi
interagiamo tra noi esseri umani e come
interagiscono le molecole perché noi tra
esseri umani possiamo fare legami deboli
oppure legami forti legami deboli Io
vado al supermercato dalla cassiera e
prendo Non lo so un pacchetto di
patatine Grazie arrivederci buonasera io
insomma con la cassiera La saluto ci
parlo un attimo chiaramente l'educazione
sempre importante Ecco quello è un
legame debole perché è un attimo è uno
strusciarsi di un secondo di atomi di
ossigeno nell'atmosfera Perché in
effetti i legami deboli le forze di
London si chiamano anche sono quelle che
fanno sì che gas in questa stanza
interagiscano tra loro ma per poco tempo
altrimenti noi se avessimo dei legami
forti tra le molecole che compongono
l'atmosfera sbatteremo costantemente la
testa contro un muro Poi ci sono i
fluidi fluidi importantissimi ora siamo
la società della fluidità per cui
Insomma bisogna conoscerli fluidi fluidi
sono importanti perché Perché sviluppano
forze sufficientemente forti da riuscire
a stare insieme ma sufficientemente
deboli da poter avere la libertà di
scorrere L'uno sull'altro e poi ci sono
i legami forti Quelli sono un esempio
bellissimo Secondo me di amore è lì che
sta la chiave legami forti come quelli
che formano il diamante il diamante è un
solido molecolare fatto di tanti atomi
di carbonio che si legano ognuno si lega
altri quattro atomi e forma questa
struttura solidissima
Ecco il legame forte per eccellenza è il
legame covalente E pensate le molecole
lo fanno singolo doppio triplo fanno
coppie troppi e fanno anche i polimeri
ammucchiate le molecole fanno il panico
ragazzi Ok Ecco il legame covalente
perché la forma d'amore più bella perché
in un legame covalente un atomo dice
all'altro caro Ti voglio prestare un
elettrone e l'altro Dai te lo presto
Anche io E da questo prestarsi elettroni
da questo andare a mettere in comune
qualcosa e questo condividere si forma
un legame tutta la natura tutta la
biologia tutta la vita in tutti
probabilmente gli universi che
conosciamo Finora abbiamo conosciuto si
basa sui legami tra cui i legami
covalenti IL dna nel suo filamento si
formano le proteine grazie ai legami
covalenti il legame peptidico nelle
proteine legame covalente i legami dei
fosfolipidi della membrana cellulare che
tengono l'interno escludono l'esterno
sono formati dal legame covale tutta la
vita per come la conosciamo sta in piedi
grazie ai legami covalenti ma legami
covalenti non sono tutte rose e fiori
ragazze perché dovete sapere che ci sono
alcuni legami covalenti in cui non
vorreste mai incappare tipo il legame
covalente polare perché vedete Vi sarà
capitato che la vostra amica vi dica Lo
vedi Lo vedi come ti tratta è tutto
sbilanciato il vostro rapporto tu lo
cerchi E lui non ti cerca tu ci vai e
lui non ti non va Insomma Praticamente i
legami sono anche sbilanciati come il
legame del povero hcl L'acido cloridrico
dove il cloro si tiene tutti gli
elettroni e il povero idrogeno sta lì e
dice sai cosa dice però l'idrogeno fa
qualcosa che dovreste consigliare alla
vostra amica l'idrogeno se ne va dal
legame perché infatti la casella è un
acido è libera protoni libera h+ e
questo lo fa perché poi a un certo punto
si stanca di avere rapporti sbilanciati
no come è l'idrogeno poi ci sono dei
legami ancora peggiori peggiori per noi
esseri umani legami nativi dove tu dai
tutto e indietro non prendi proprio
nulla Questo è il legame delle famose
crocerossine o crocerossine perché ci
sono anche gli uomini che fanno questo
non sono solo le donne perché sennò
altrimenti uno dice ma invece ci sono
tanti ragazzi che si peròstano si
mettono lì dico Prendi tutto da me e non
voglio niente sbagliato sbagliato però
questo è uno dei legami che serve a
formare Beh il cloruro di ammonio che
tra l'altro un importante fertilizzante
per cui anche le crociere uscite e croce
Rossini Insomma hanno la loro utilità Ma
cosa succede nel cervello Ecco nel
cervello la nostra idea d'amore si forma
Grazie all'interazione di tantissime
molecole e potrei star qui ora parlarvi
del fatto che quando abbiamo il famoso
colpo di fulmine probabilmente abbiamo
dei picchi di ossitocina che inonda il
nostro cervello Oppure potrei dirvi che
ehm Beh la quando si dice a quello
quello è un maschio Alfa Ecco il maschio
Alfa tutti dicono eh produce tanto
testosterone No no è la vasopressina è
la vasopressina Ma poi anche potrei
dirvi come svelare geneticamente se il
vostro compagno è predisposto al
tradimento Perché sì si può sapere Ci
sono delle predisposizioni genetiche
proprio nei dei promotori dei recettori
della vasopressina nei promotori dei
geni che codificano per I recettori
della vasopressina si trovano delle
variabilità tali Per cui alcuni
individui sono più predisposti alla
monogamia e altri non lo sono ma ha
senso farsi queste domande ha senso
capire così nel dettaglio La somma delle
cose deterministiche che portano
all'amore Io non penso proprio penso che
l'amore sia bello per l'essere la sua
proprietà emergente e poi sappiate che
potreste avere anche un gene che vi
predispone una certa malattia e quella
malattia non averla mai tutta la vita La
cosa che però ci insegna la natura e
L'osservazione delle molecole è qualcosa
che va contro la dialettica del contro
natura quando vi diranno ma questa cosa
non la fare perché è contro natura Ecco
le persone che parlano di contro natura
dovrebbero guardare agli atomi che si
legano tra di loro indipendentemente
intanto da che altro atomo si trovano di
fronte indipendentemente dal colore
delle loro maglie indipendentemente da
tutto quello che li circonda gli atomi
Fanno ciò che vogliono si respingono
quando vogliono respingersi e si legano
quando vogliono legarsi lo fanno Fin
dall'antichità da quando è nato
praticamente l'universo Quella è la
natura che queste persone dovrebbero
osservare quando ne parlano Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]